aaron judge not playing today he should
be back tomorrow the right-hander jorge
lopez on the mound so glebert torres
coming up scoreless game first inning
this is his 11th start nowhere runs
against him in the first franco will
continue that streak with a fine play at
third and it is a one two three first
for jorge lopez
you see jordan montgomery on the year
opponents just hitting 190 off of him
and his walks are low so mullins gives
him a good start with a single to left
and here is right hand hitting austin
hayes
and the pitch a bunt a push punt fielded
by lemayo going to be a tough play
and they get him
montgomery got to first moving to second
is mullins
that was a nice bunt by hayes but the
yankees turned it into an out
so here's trey mancini with mullins in
second
o2 here and trade digs one out and sends
it back up the box for a base hit
mullins will score in the orioles around
the board first on an rbi single from
trey manciti i think it was a changeup
and he hit him with one hand here's gary
sanchez 10 for 55 on the season man in
the scoring position representing the
tying run
2-1 for sanchez
and that is well struck into left field
austin hayes though is johnny on the
spot and lopez is out of the scoreless
second inning
and that will bring up the left-handed
dj stewart
let's see if they can turn two there's
one throw to first
there's two nice play by odor
and not only odor or actually claber
nice little pick there at the end from
lemayo
yes that was glaber because of the ship
my apologies thank you david
clay frazier digs in against jorge lopez
as clint fraser lines one to first ryan
mount castle how do you do
he took away extra bases from clint
frazier what a play by young ryan mount
castle and a big first down here in the
third so two down for taurus as the
yankees construct a rally here in the
third
on two and two he hit the outside corner
at 97. lopez pitches out of trouble in
the third
and they have two on and two out and
here is clint
frazier was middle of the plate for
frasier in the air to right d.j stewart
at the wall he has just enough room and
jorge lopez stands on the mound takes a
deep breath and walks slowly back to the
orioles dugout he kept frazier in the
ballpark and the orioles still have a
one-nothing lead there is severino to
lead off
that one's lined to right field frazier
will play it off the wall plays the
caramel and holds severino to a single
well well done by frasier it almost got
by him but a nice recovery showing his
athleticism and
it's no small thing play that well you
hold him to a single now here's mount
castle fly ball shallow right coming on
it's fraser and he dives to make the
play fires to first
not in time
so frazier took a hit away from mount
castle and look at that in the heel the
glove holds on to it shades flying
severino got a scamper
now it is up to adam
let's go and the oriole
bullpen
base is loaded two outs it'll be pletco
against root neto door the o1
that one is ripped into right field it's
a basic gardener will score
lemay who will score it's a big two-run
single for root nettle door and the
yankees lead two to one well there's one
away and here is cedric mullins he's one
for two
swing and a miss
he gets mullins for the second out
something about a lefty a lefty changeup
they just don't see it
see how far out in front mullins is he
is a free pass to sanchez to start the
inning and brings up frasier
crown ball to shortstop maria swan
valeika two six four three double play
turn by the oriole infield the orioles
do have
the middle of the lineup up mancini will
start
and trey drills it left center field
this ball is off the top of the wall and
into the oriole bullpen
he ties the game
and they're going crazy in the o's pen
as mancini picks up his fifth home run
of the year
you said you're hoping he could trend
one out of here he did just that 111 off
the bat yep and then of course if you're
really a good hitter at the top of the
wall three hits today that one knocks
out montgomery ties the game at two
yankees go to the pen that brings us to
chad green here's ryan mount castle with
two outs
here's a slider cutout i missed
one run one hit no one left and we have
played six we're tied at two travis
laken senior comes on he's been
spectacular labor torres digs in stanton
leads him first mine then there's a
perfect double play ball and aureus to
second on to first there it is double
play
pletco had one turn behind him in the
last inning
lakins gets the twin killing here paul
frye who's just been spectacular and now
aaron judge is going to come up with a
man at first
strike three 94 above the zone and judge
did chase the gym
now sanchez pitch in
he swings and breaks his back ball
bounces behind second valenca's got it
throws to first right on the money
sanchez retired and paul fryde does his
job putting a scoreless top of the
eighth together and the new pitcher is
the former oriole
daryn o'day lead off walk to cedric
mullins in a tie game in the eighth
inning and brings austin hayes up to the
plate he's swinging away and ripping one
in the left center field mullins turbos
for third here he goes to third he's
waved in by tony mancellino he will
score and the ball kicks away hayes will
go to third the orioles have the lead as
austin hayes brings in cedric mullins
from first
slider in the middle of the plate austin
hayes who's been heating up and cesar
valdez will look to pick up the final
three outs go ahead runs are on base
here comes giancarlo stanton
got him swinging strike three
yankees down to their final strike
and the pitch that one has driven to
left field and deep gibby chase's haze
he can't get there it bounces over the
wall for a double and the yankees have
tied the game at three
a huge hit for gleber torres
and on the mound
this is where all this chapman's he
struck out mount castle and stewart
here's ramon marias and the one-two
swing and a miss at 102. he strikes out
the side and we go to extra innings
tanner scott will come on uh in the 10th
inning geo rochelle made the final out
of the previous inning so he will start
at second base as the ghost runner ford
came in as a pinch hitter in the ninth
walked against cesar valdez
he won't hear tight sliders strike three
scott does his job and the orioles all
they need is one to end it and the new
pitcher for the yankees is going to be
jonathan lowisiga
wrist can run a little bit so there's
your winning run right there base hit
wins it sacrifice fly wins it yankees
are in at the corners
and mullins is swinging away
in the air to left center is it deep
enough hicks makes the catch here comes
urias and the orioles win it on a
sacrifice fly from mullins
4-3 final for a series split with the
yankees